did you catch what you said about um
men and women's tennis is different i
would just write it down i just wrote it
down here but i want to i want to stay
on this and we'll come back to this with
the men and men and women matter of fact
let's just address it right now since
you brought it up
you know there was an interview i saw
where serena's with jimmy kimmel i think
it's kimmel i don't think it's found i
think it's kimmel and well you know you
think you can get out there and compete
with man he's like no no no i just want
to compete with he says you don't
understand uh for me to go up against
andy murray there is no way i can
compete against andy murray you know
it's a very different game the muscles
are different and she just unpacks it
for
jimmy and jimmy's kind of like not
wanting to hear that message because
jimmy wants to say you know
women can go out and compete with men
for somebody who's coached both sides
you know do do what do you think about
what serena said do you agree with her
that it's very very different to have a
woman compete against them because she
said it was a different sport
the weight she said i would lose six or
if you want to put the story up john i
would lose 6060 in five minutes they
told a
i don't know what article i was reading
that said one of the
uh not professional the amateur ranking
that they have they said 450th place of
amateur ranking for men's would be the
women's number one some weird number
like that do you agree with that or do
you have this came in the height of the
thomas william thomas swimming debate
whatever number
he was and then became number one in the
world anyway tennis tennis is you know
that's kind of tricky but i agree 100
percent with serena she's right and you
go look when she's saying it she's
coming from fact she you know it
wouldn't be five minutes it would be
longer than that and she might scrape a
game or two if she popped a few serves
into the corner but it's just more
physical the guys cover more real estate
on the court because they're just bigger
and stronger it doesn't mean the the
girls wouldn't participate you would
have four eight maybe some ten ball
rallies but it'd be
a slow death to the end then bang you
know it's in the serves i mean come on
one twenty
these guys are hitting 140. so
what do the women serve tops
they can go into the 120 but the guys
are let's say at the corner it's coming
back it's you're talking 140 versus 120
max yeah but it's not even the serve i
mean you still got to get it in and
you're only serving half the match so
it's and it's just it's i don't want to
say it's a different sport because
listen the women are amazing the guys
just cover more real estate you don't
realize it because both guys are
covering the real estate you know it's a
it's like a a good high school guy
bringing the ball up in the nba yeah
dribbling the ball if the guy wanted to
he could steal it from him every time
but you don't see that in the nba
because other guys this is good here's
what's crazy about this though here's
what's great you know how sometimes
they'll say wow women don't make enough
the same amount of money as men doing
soccer you know how that conversation oh
women basketball doesn't make as much
money as nba players i'm completely okay
watching women's tennis maybe more than
men's tennis it's so weird it's not the
interest is there because it's still
competitive and yes serena and venus and
these girls are making a lot of money
they're making millions on top of
millions of dollars of money the dollar
is not that big of a difference for the
comparable to the eyeballs that they're
getting versus in basketball how many
people are watching wnba or watching you
know this is a story tyler just pulled
up if you want to put it up fc dallas
under 15 boys squad beat the u.s women's
national team in a scrimmage i mean he
says in soccer this isn't soccer yeah
this is when you kind of see
that there's certain sports it doesn't
uh
it doesn't help anyways i saw serena
talking about well let's go back to
let's go back to the coaching style so
your coaching style would you say
uh uh did you did you mirror any other
coaches from other sports
like are you a john wooden guy could you
sound like a john wooden guy
um a few other people have said that not
not really you know i i think growing up
in the midwest and you know just how i
was brought up from my mom and just
you know it's from the heart you gain
the knowledge as you go down the yellow
brick road you know and you always got
to want to continue your education but
the ability to educate motivate you know
it's it's it's that and so i really
never
the biggest influence would be probably
dr jim lehrer who was the number one
sports psychologist that we spent some
time together in the early 80s he was a
pioneer and now there's many guys out
there but he was the first of the
mohicans in my opinion he was a pioneer
so and i was always intrigued with the
mental part that's how i became kind of
good in my own little bubble uh of not
having a lesson didn't he write a book
or something he's wrong about 20 yeah
but he had that one book that was mental
toughness training oh that was the first
this guy's a legend by the way no no
jim's like one of my best friends have
you read any of this guy's books i'm not
familiar with it it's insane if you pull
anyway so yeah so he so he yeah
yeah so you know and we used to play all
the time yeah you know when this was
early 80s at green leaf so that would be
really the only person i never you know
you get the knowledge as you go on and
it's just
your love and concern for the person and
you know when you see the movie you know
it comes across loud and clear how
bernthal played me even though even
though his mustache looked like a shrub
room i had this little piece of
astroturf it took me 30 years to grow um
you could see
how much i cared for the girls and that
richard was my best friend and we were
just on a mission and when you
when your students feel that that you
would do anything you can get them to
jump over mountains and everybody feels
that way um
when i'm on the court with them it
doesn't matter just the way i'm wired
that's all if you enjoyed this short
clip click over here to watch another
short clip and if you want to watch the
entire episode the entire podcast click
here
[Music]